so ethical fading is a
really amazing and fascinating social
phenomenon
uh basically what it is is when a group
of people
make unethical decisions
believing that they ha are still
consistent with their own ethical
framework in other words they don't
think they've done anything unethical
right extreme examples of this
would be
things like um a pharmaceutical company
raising the price of an essential
uh uh
a drug
uh 500 percent eight hundred percent a
thousand percent five thousand percent
and though it may not be illegal
it's highly highly unethical
and and yet they don't think they've
done anything wrong
um
uh that's an extreme example but we see
ethical fading happen all across
companies all the time um where we do
things that we know
are good for us where we might lie to
our our customers or our clients for
example or we might lie to each other
to get ourselves ahead you know this is
all these are all demonstrations of
ethical fading
the way in which ethical fading happens
as you said one of the ways is just a
ridiculous unbalanced amount of
pressure on short term
which forces us to think about ourselves
or or uh only think about
that short-term goal
um and then we can rationalize well
everyone's doing it
it's what the company wants me to do how
else am i going to get ahead i have to
put food on the table it's the system
it's you know like we can rationalize
the behavior
um the also the slippery slope we do
something a little bit once it worked we
do it a little more it works we do a
little more it works it do it and before
you know it you have full blown ethical
fading
and so the way you combat ethical fading
and and like i said i gave you an
extreme example of the pharmaceuticals
but we see low-level ethical fading
across a lot of companies unfortunately
and the way you combat it is uh is one
uh
good leadership
where that kind of thing is not
tolerated
so for example it's
it's totally normal for people to have
unethical ideas
but the question is when when do they
get caught so in an unhealthy company
that that unethical idea is implemented
until social pressure or the law
intervenes or there's a scandal
right and then we say oh we're terribly
sorry we you know we're a very good
company
after you got caught in a in a properly
ethical company somebody may raise the
idea in a meeting
and everybody in the meeting will go
that's funny but we would never do that
here
that's that's not us that's a little bit
unethical and we get it gets shut down
immediately
and again that's good leadership because
it's the leaders
who are promoting people who are ethical
who are highlighting ethical behavior
and acting in a way that sets the tone
and they're not putting undue pressure
on people to break the rules in order to
make the numbers
um you know a lot of leaders
unfortunately when confronted with
toxicity or an ethical behavior they'll
shrug their strollers and say i know but
the numbers are so good and they allow
it to happen
and so one of the primary ways in which
you beat ethical fading quite frankly is
is good leadership but the others are
just cause you know trusting teams all
of these things contribute to operating
in a highly ethical way